Meeting other game developers
you see how much raw passsion
there is out there.
You just want to share your
knowledge and soak up the
inspiration.
Playing games is very different
from making games.
We had to learn a lot and it was
a lot of hard work.
You have to keep working on the
same game for a long time.
You have to learn how to code.
It's not just dreaming and
playing games.
Hi my name is Gerald Tock
and i'm the CEO of Inzen Studio
in Singapore.
Dark Dot is a hybrid game
of sorts.
It's a classic "shoot'em up"
but instead of just fast paced
movement, we slow it down by
having a tactical element that
uses shape manipulation.
Indie Developers Day taught us
how to tie our ideas
to the data
and really dig deep into
understanding how users respond
to changes.
Just recently, analytics helped
us to test out a new
store listing
which increased our downloads
by 25 percent.
Being able to fully understand
what the platform offers
connects us better with
our players.
Now we have more than 200,000
downloads, and the editor's
choice award.
My name is Yogie Aditya
and i'm the CTO of Niji Games
based in Yogjakarta.
We knew we wanted to make a good
puzzle game.
That was most important.
after many months we built a
game we love playing
and launched it on Google Play.
Everybody thought Cute Munchies
was great.
We were getting downloads and
5 star reviews, but nobody would
keep playing the game.
Google told us about how to give
the user reasons to play longer
and more often.
They showed us how to implement
the game save feature and the
Google Play game services.
We tried to optimize the
store listings and the icons
the downloads increased
93 percent and the revenue
increased by 51 percent.
and user retention improved in
the first week.
Now we can think about the
future, about making more
complex games.
My name is Vinh Nguyen
and my friends and i make games
for V-Games in Vietnam.
It took 2 years to develop
Gungun.
We were building the game we
wanted to play.
But we ended up with almost
no revenue.
We thought about building
another game, but what if
we failed again.
We decided to keep trying
we had to make it work.
We met a mentor from Google
he said our game was great.
but we needed to build in ways
to make money.
We added a VIP package for
paid users, and allowed users to
buy any mobiles and characters
directly.
Right away, our revenue
increased 100 percent in
one day.
We ended up number 2
on the Play website.
It's the passion of our staff
that comes through
for us always.
We have cosplayers, artists and
playful spirits in the company
that inspire our
design philosophy.
Don't worry about being indie
If you try and have passion,
you will find a way.
We are playing a bigger
game now.
But we are still playing.